I think the majority of social  progressives are white supremacists so  that's why I actually think we should  keep the word in the Lexicon because  these people are so if you say the only  way that Adam can succeed is if I do  something for him that places you above  me correct it makes you stronger than me  because I can't do for myself and that  is the environment that we currently  live in as far as in the media and as  far as the how even the government  operates now there's poor black people  they need our help right no I totally  get it and I think one of the things you  talk about in the black victim to Black  Victor is the idea of having a victim  requires a savior absolutely and so this  ideology is particularly appealing to  certain people who want to be victims  and want government help or other people  to look after them or whatever but even  more so it's really appealing to people  who want to help the poor downtrodden  black and brown people exactly